today we are talking about finding
sponsors a couple ideas here the first
one is be the authority in your industry
and this is how I started getting my
first sponsors is that people knew me as
being the entrepreneur guy first off
just in my city like I'm the
entrepreneur guy in Toronto and for this
to happen it has to be really Niche how
do I Niche down so that people find me
because if you're just talking about
motivation you're up against Tony
Robbins and Mel Robbins and Eric Thomas
and Evan Carmichael and all these big
channels so why would a giant company
want to work with you at least why would
they come to you they wouldn't be your
first choice to come to you so I was
thinking about how can I be the go-to in
my specific industry and one of the
biggest things that I found too for
helping people get more business from
YouTube is going more Niche like who
specifically do you help and making
content directly geared towards them
this is something that you and I have
been working on and helping some of his
clients he's helped some clients get
five six figure deals from their YouTube
channels and they have a hundred
subscribers
yeah because the videos are specific
right so who do you ideally want to be
helping and making content directly
towards them and so a lot of a lot of
times the problem is our content is too
General it's too broad
yeah and you're going up against big
people and so you won't be the one that
they find but some of the stuff that
that he puts up is is relatively obscure
a niche like how can a dentist uh invest
in life insurance
is a pretty specific Niche thing
and the goal isn't to have a million
views on that video but anybody who's
watching that video is going to be an
ideal target market for you
and so if if I'm a dentist and I'm
trying to invest in life insurance and I
find that video there aren't probably
too many videos there's videos talking
about how dentists can grow a business
or entrepreneurs and grow business this
video is talking about life insurance
but not that combination and in that
combination we start to get people
who are our ideal clients
so it's yes building up
I love that you're building the giant
channels what I love doing but I also
want you to make money along the way and
if you have any kind of client service
business or products that you want to
sell making it specific knowing that
we're not trying to get a million
subscribers yet on these videos but it
can start to pay us it also attracts the
attention of potential sponsors
so the the more Niche you can get
especially when the channel is small the
more Niche you can get the more people
will find you who care about that Niche
so Pablo's doing negotiation in Spanish
and he's the only one talking about that
and now he's getting 10 000 subscribers
this week we love it congrats fan you
know who cares about reaching that
audience right who who are the companies
who are the organizations that care of a
reaching out audience and if he's the
only one how many channels are there
Pablo making Spanish negotiation content
I I can't find any any other one the
only thing that they have a marketing he
may you know Marketing sales
um negotiation and persuasion no I I
don't I don't have any other one that
that I can I can see you know great no
yeah so so when advertisers
organizations corporations want to
Target his audience he's the only one
doing it
now if it was if it was Spanish and
business as other channels out there
which was just Spanish there's tons of
channels it was just negotiations tons
of channels but in that combination in
that Niche is how he starts to win Drew
says 500 now uh oh this clients have 500
subscribers yeah but that's great like
500 subscribers and you're getting five
and six figure deals from your YouTube
channel
so this works being the authority
industry works for attracting sponsors
to us as opposed to us going out trying
to find sponsors right this is always my
favorite
because I'm not I don't enjoy the sales
part of it I love the marketing but not
the sales part of it
um Drew says five to six figure deals
weekly at this point from the channel
so five to six figure deals every week
from a Channel with 500 subscribers
right just by being Niche like this this
is now he has a service to sell right so
what do you guys sell what's the service
but again the more Niche you can make it
the more people will find you that's not
so much sponsorships that's clients
right but sponsors as well
if you are the expert in the industry
people will come and want to work with
you
okay next I'd look at who is sponsoring
uh your competitors so if you're gonna
now start doing some Outreach to find
some sponsors for us like who is our
biggest competitor and where are they
getting their sponsors so if I were to
look at my channel I don't do sponsors
like paid sponsors usually more
uh hassle than it's worth
but at the beginning I did a lot more
now very I'm very selective also because
um
I want to actually in if it's on my
Channel I want to actually feel like I
like the product or service so I'm very
particular I have to actually be using
it so that makes it a challenge for a
lot of sponsors because
if I'm not using it and they're not
really interested in a long-term
commitment then I don't I don't work
with them
um so for me look at Tom bilyu Right Tom
bily use in my my Niche my industry
um let me see what this one is so he
just posted this an hour ago
so it says includes a paid promotion
and we can go find it
so it says in description this this
episode is sponsored by Future future
makes one-on-one training available to
your audience for 19 go to True try
future.com I've never heard of future
this is probably something health
related this is not a great competitor
of mine because I don't really talk
about health and fitness that much but
if you did who's try future you know
these guys could be potential sponsors
for your content they're already the
benefit of this is they already care
about sponsoring YouTube content you
don't have to convince them to sponsor
YouTube content they're already in the
game they already have a model they
already have a budget assigned towards
towards it so now they're just the
challenge to me and I Know Who You Are
just make an introduction to them and
say hey I've got similar content I
Target this audience do you want to do
something together so this is more kind
of entrepreneurial right mindset this
would be a better fit for me aura.com
impact
so protect yourself from identity theft
so this is kind of more broad but you
know I've never heard of Ori either I
could reach out to them right just go
one by one look at who's doing paid
promotion
um in your competition and
contact them this is a mix
so Gary if I look at who my competition
is you know Gary I don't think is doing
any paid sponsorships uh Grant Cardone
doesn't do paid sponsorships Mel Robbins
doesn't do paid sponsorships uh Jim this
Brad I don't think Brad Jim's Jim's from
Brad Bradley's channel does Brad dude
sponsorships on any videos
no sir
yeah so most people in thought
leadership aren't really doing
sponsorships
it's just them it's trying to build
their own personal brand up
uh 123 let's go we got to get us to half
a million now what's the next step
uh but that's a great option so look at
any of your competitors see who's
sponsoring on there and those are
potential options for you okay it's just
an Outreach and here for the first one
be the authority you may have to
convince them to get on YouTube
you know like if Pablo has the biggest
audience for negotiation in Spanish on
YouTube there's organizations that do
care about that market but they may not
be interested in YouTube yet
so the conversation is now here's why
you need to be on YouTube Here's how we
can do something together that's a
conversation where but this one they're
already convinced ARA is already
convinced about YouTube they're already
spending money there now we need to get
them to give us some of their budget on
it
in terms of making sponsor content too
there's a couple ways to do it uh the
way Tom does it is he'll he'll mix it
into he'll do a plug somewhere in here
uh somewhere in the middle of the video
he'll do yeah he'll do like this this
video is brought to you by Aura like he
interrupts his video halfway through
this is a 52 minute video and we're at
the 25 minute mark
so he'll say something quick at the
beginning this video is brought to you
by Aura like two seconds and then
somewhere in the middle of the video
he'll spend a couple minutes talking
about it and doing screenshots uh my
favorite way is to actually do
a collaboration with them so I had a
three-year deal with with sage I think
you guys know Sage it's a software
company they do accounting software I
move myself my accounting software over
to them so that I could say I'm a sage
customer and for three years I did a
monthly video with their CEO it's the
CEO of sage multi-billion dollar company
and him and I went live on YouTube once
a month answering questions
and just trying to give value to the
entrepreneur Community wasn't even
promoting because accounting software is
so boring who wants to talk about
accounting software right it's like the
worst thing
ever for most most entrepreneurs so the
goal was just to put a friendly face to
the corporation and give a lot of value
so that was how we structured our deal
um three years of just doing monthly q
and A's with my audience as opposed to
something like this but this can also
work as well uh just what do you prefer
so who's sponsoring your competitors
another great option
today's topic how do
you how to some kind of offer I love it
and this is super important because it's
not just about
getting subscribers and Views most of
you I hope want to build a business
right we're not just trying to be
influencers we're trying to actually
build a business try to make money doing
this uh just so we can hire team and
reach more people and continue to expand
our reach I've got 30 something people
my team uh that doesn't happen if I'm
not you know making money from the
videos it's great to have however many
millions of subscribers and Views and
all that but we have to be able to turn
it into something
um and with with offers you can also go
deeper with people okay to show the
process
this is not so much of a hardcore sales
strategy more of taking me deep into
what you're naturally already great at
so that it makes me curious that I want
to reach out to you that I want to check
out your your profile that I want to
find your website that I want to do some
kind of work with you so two weeks ago
uh when we had Paul on he had shared on
one of his channels I forget how many
subscribers this channel has Paul maybe
you can remind us in the chat I think it
was in the in the low hundreds of
subscribers
he was posting these short videos and
you know three minute videos here and it
had 34 views and he does hypnosis and
then he posted a full video of his stage
work of him doing a full show it was it
was an hour and a half and this was not
with any pay this is all organic got 4
000 views her Channel with a couple
hundred subscribers that's fantastic and
we use that in the context of
longer videos work it's really hard to
get a three minute video to rank so
longer videos work I'd love to see at
least the 10 minute mark
but if you can go an hour and a half
that's fantastic we're getting some of
our best results with three hour videos
eight hour videos though mashing up
pieces together could be really good
um and I'd love to see
just trying to go longer on the content
maybe you can get that to six seven
eight you'll start to see better results
with where YouTube's at right now
that was what we talked about a couple
weeks ago though but for this it's
showing the process so if Paul's got a
great hypnosis show if he keeps putting
out the show even if he never says hire
me even if he never says buy my book or
buy my course or bring me to your event
or I do corporate gigs even if he never
says that just showing the process will
get people who want to work with him
I got my first speaking gig uh that's
not you not my first degree but one of
my first speaking gigs my first like big
speaking gig I guess the first where I
was the keynote speaker I was in Kuala
Lumpur and I got flown in
because the guy had seen my YouTube
videos
and I never
had anywhere in my videos hey hire me if
you need someone to speak hire me hire
me hire me because I was showing me
speaking
people reached out and wanted to hire me
to come and speak I still got a lot of
my speaking gigs now mostly virtual I'm
all virtual right now but I still get
them all because people see me speak on
my YouTube videos even though there's
nowhere actually in any of my sequences
or funnels or anything that talks about
me being a speaker or or hiring me they
see it and they want more so Paul if
Paul kept putting on these hypnosis
shows
that's what he does again I know right
now might be a little difficult during
covet but if he's putting on those shows
he will get corporations and
organizations reaching out to say hey
how can we work with you I love that
show you did can you make that happen
for us
make sense Paul says yeah that channel
hat was a little more a little over a
hundred right so Channel this again
shows the process of what you're great
at this required less work to do than a
lot of his
full-on videos where he's direct the
camera because it's just taping the show
and and there was no editing on this and
no fancy music or anything it was just
the actual show and it did really well
for him so um congrats was he saying
since I put that full stage hypnosis
video I'm up over 1 000 on views view
time and new subscribers in the last 28
days I love it dude that's great and it
was just an experiment so congrats and
again going along showing your process
makes a huge difference
uh next
let's get to to you guys so Ashley uh I
don't know if Ashley's here in the house
but Ashley uh is from the tapping
solution and they
um I know I know the founders uh um uh
Nick ortner started this company with
his family and they help you get rid of
your stress through tapping and if you
go to their Facebook page you go to
their website or you go to their their
content you'll see all of these amazing
people doing tapping so you see Dr Oz
doing tapping you'll see them teaching
Wayne Dyer how did it happen and and I
don't know all the ins and outs but
you're tapping all the different you
know you got you tap in here you tap in
here and you're tapping on your wrists
and showing people how to tap Jennifer
says she loves tapping
uh so it's great and they have all these
case studies and testimonials and videos
well here's what's interesting when you
go to their Facebook page look at the
top the biggest call to action right
here is use the app
and this is where you have to understand
what is the business goal that you're
trying to accomplish where do we want to
drive people what do we want people to
know about us Beyond just watching our
videos in education what ultimately
we're trying to sell are we trying to
sell a coaching program are you trying
to sell stage work shows are you trying
to sell an app a book mentorship like
what are you actually trying to sell and
then showing me the process of doing it
so if I look at this page I think
and I know a little bit about the
company anyway but even if I didn't I'd
say okay they want to promote their app
so what should the videos be on their
Channel somebody using the app
instead of Nick just guiding people
through how to do this it should be Nick
doing
loading the app and saying okay today
we're going to do our
our tapping on anxiety are we going to
do our tapping on
uh whatever it is you're gonna tap away
there's like so many versions of tapping
that they have inside their app having
somebody actually load the app and then
do one of the free tapping sessions as a
video without even having to say that
this is a free app or there's a 90-day
trial or you know whatever offer you've
got just the fact that you're using it
makes me curious to say oh my gosh how
do I how do I get a part of it
Ashley says this is for Ashley she's
writing so you think you should like
listen to The Meditation that's in the
app versus walking people through the
meditation that's interesting yes if
your goal is to get people to use the
app
right so if your goal is I want people
to sign up for our app which as I
believe that's the goal yeah okay so she
confirmed that that's the goal then I
want to see Nick or whoever come on
camera load the app and say okay today
we're going to do a meditation from our
tapping solution app this is great for
without improving the app this is great
for whatever like again benefits of
tapping benefits meditation okay let's
press play and let's dive in again
you're showing me the process what do
you want to sell and then show me the
process of you actually using the thing
so it's not this this jointed thing
afterwards so not just somebody
meditating one of the other Founders
meditating and then saying by the way
we've got this free app that can help
you show me how to use in the process
right
uh I pulled out Jennifer so uh Jennifer
had this great post on Instagram uh
shout out to Jennifer I see her here
live too
and she wrote so here at the top when my
tot throws a tantrum I just start
breathing the calm myself the flip down
I love it then I think what was the
thing from that one parenting podcast or
book I read on how to deal with this and
then I highlighted this part on days
like these I'm definitely wearing a
piece of uh child sedoni
close enough all right uh which has
calming properties and helps me reduce
anger and doubt okay what would be great
as content so this is something
everybody can relate to right every
parent can definitely relate to this and
I think about you know my son or my
nieces or nephews uh they're a little
beyond that stage now you know they're
like uh 10 years old but when they were
younger just constantly freaking out and
feeling like you're making mistakes
everywhere and you're the you know edge
of your patient Zone I would love to see
this as a video
so instead of just showing you know your
arm and then I can see the the you know
the it's not a bead the jewelry here and
here
show me you going through it my
son is freaking out and it's driving me
crazy
and so here's what I do when this
happens
you see this Stone here's here's what it
does
here's Hawaii has healing properties and
so and then whatever you do whether you
sit down and you look at it or you just
put it on or you meditate with it
um
so show what picture it's a video show a
video of you freaking out
with you with like your hair all over
the place and you stressing out like
right here this this basically I want to
see it happening instead of you just
showing this perfect picture
I want to see you being the mom with a
tot who's freaking out and you're trying
to calm yourself down
and and then what do you do like how do
you actually get calm well the jewelry
helps you get calm and there's a process
that you go through that I would love to
see that as a video maybe maybe you're
tapping as well maybe it's a combination
of the of the jewelry and the tapping
but whatever you do to make that
actually work
um
as a video you don't even then have to
sell or promote the jewelry you're doing
it through the process of showing me how
you uh are getting out of this struggle
that you're dealing with with your
taught right so it's it's much more
effective than just having this is great
copy the picture is great but I don't
see you freaking out or stressed out or
needing the Comm to flip down which
would be great to see even if you're
doing Instagram copy this could be a
good Carousel picture of you like but
real like this was me today not some
fake like you and a green screen pulling
hair but this is actually me today and
here's what happened and then the next
one over is this that's a good Instagram
strategy but for YouTube
how many how many moms uh because I know
that's your that's your tribe how many
moms are struggling with with their kids
and stressing out and freaking out and
you know so showing me that you are one
of them and here's how to get through it
and here's how you get through it and
this is what you do
um some people will think well that's
ridiculous like jewelry can't help me do
that and other people will be like
that's amazing what's the name of that
thing ciao sedoni how do I get one
how do I where's your website
so you're just showing me the process of
you doing that thing
it's hard to film during attention
hahaha very smart thanks yeah even even
think about it afterwards like you you
you're not gonna and you probably don't
want to film your child freaking out
behind you right just for privacy and
and everything else but after it's
happened you're still stressed out you
finally put them down or or somebody's
taking over or they're having a snack or
they're napping or whatever and you're
still but you're still feeling the
emotions of feeling
overwhelmed and like a failure and not
knowing what to do and needing a break
and having too much anxiety and so
that's when you make the video
this is so valuable I appreciate this
Insight
um awesome hey that's what we're here
for brand Linux let's go
I'm excited this is a this is a fun
topic this is something that I obsess
over how do we get our one minute
audience retention it's it's a super
geeky topic of all the things that um
that I
try to teach when I'm doing
presentations uh this is the only thing
that I get technical with the audience
retention curve the audience retention
curve the audience retention curve like
remember this thing pay attention to it
look at your data because it's easy to
get lost in YouTube data but this one is
super super important understand that
YouTube's goal is to keep you on YouTube
right that's their goal so the more
you're keeping people on YouTube the
more they're going to promote your
videos and so many people focus on
the entire video which is important but
what often happens is if you get the
first minute down really well and you're
keeping people for for that attention
they'll watch the rest of the video If
you go look at most of your curves you
you'll see it's mostly flat or just
slowly sloping down but that first mint
is where we tend to lose people so
people are often shocked if you go look
at your own stats people are often
shocked at how poorly their videos are
doing in that first minute so today
that's what we are talking about let me
share my screen boom specific strategies
that boost viewer retention I'm excited
okay let's dive in so the goal
the goal is 70 at one minute this is uh
this is a really hard number to hit
especially consistently nobody hits this
number consistently not not inside
thought leadership I don't do it nobody
that I've looked at does it
um
it's really really really really hard
and I've looked at everybody's Channel
at least the big Channel since I thought
leadership but it's still the goal it's
still it's still that elusive here's
what we're working towards and this
curve that's the honest attention curve
you'll see this on every single video
this is free
um inside YouTube Studio product uh you
can get lost again in data but this one
is super super important and it'll show
you basically where people are falling
off so wherever you know here whatever
happened here that sucks then that was
good then that sucks and then that
sucked at the end and then these little
Peaks here this is what we're going to
share to social content right we've
talked about this in the past but uh
just quick refresh
this slide is one of you guys may have
seen in the past one minute retention
this video we did had 73 at one minute
has almost three million views on the
channel and this is what a typical Curve
will look like right it should be slowly
just declining over time and it's this
part that we're really trying to
optimize in this first minute trying to
make sure that we're keeping it not that
big a slump so you'll always get this
you'll always get this little drop here
at the beginning the key is not making
that drop and losing 40 of our audience
which happens to a lot a lot a lot a lot
a lot of channels
so here's something that we haven't
talked about yet that I wanted to just
bring up on your radar tubebuddy has a
tool that I requested uh and help them
build called the retention analyzer now
it's a little buggy and they don't
update it very often because they
basically made it for me and and some of
the people who like using it
um but it's not part of their core thing
that like everybody's using it for but
if you are using tubebuddy for split
testing right now
two buddies of tool that we use we've
done over 10 000 split tests on the
channel thumbnails titles Etc
if you're on that program you're on that
package I think that's 50 bucks a month
something like that it's not it's not
crazy expensive they have something
built in here as well called retention
analyzer
so if you go to your tubebuddy you click
on data and insights on the left and
then scroll down to retention analyzer
it'll pull up your most recent it's not
all it says all videos it's not it's
going to be your most recent I think 50
videos and then you can sort by
retention at various time stamps so I'd
say with sort by the one minute Mark and
see where you're at and you can just get
a sense of how well you're doing which
videos are performing well which videos
aren't uh just to give you a sense you
know instead of having to Go videos one
by one by one by one by one this will
help you give get an over overall sense
and see where you're doing well and
which videos uh are not doing so well
and we need to make a few adjustments to
help your channel grow so I would
definitely check that out if you're if
you're on the package for the split
testing you're already paying for this
anyway so you might as well take a look
and see which videos are performing well
and where there's some room for
improvement okay so today we're going to
talk about a lot of the dues but before
that I want to talk about some of the
don't do so this is the things you want
to avoid when you're starting your video
okay these will these will destroy your
audience retention curve
intros hi I'm Evan and I XYZ right no
intros live stream welcomes are the
worst you know a live stream
the first couple minutes usually really
really really suck on the live stream
you're welcoming people you're saying hi
you're asking about their day that's
great for a live stream environment but
not great for a YouTube video again
we're trying to assume the people who
are watching our videos don't know who
we are that's our target audience we're
not talking to our subscribers we're
talking to our non-subscribers this is
the first time they're seeing you so we
want to hit them with something that's
going to be really powerful don't do a
Sizzle reel
you getting out of your car looking
fancy or on stage looking like a special
person like none of that stuff really
brings in a lot of attention uh call to
actions we don't want call to action at
the beginning because we lose people
you'll see a big drop in your honest
attention curve
um and then Audio Only Audio Only is
really hard we're I'm working on a
couple strategies actually with some
podcasters like how do I turn my podcast
into a YouTube video when I don't have
video when it's just an audio stream and
every time I've seen it it's really
tanked but if you can make it visually
appealing I think there's a case I think
there just hasn't been a lot of
innovation on the podcast inside for how
you can play with visuals so these are
all the don't Do's don't do any of these
things and if you're looking at your
data and you're seeing that you're
you're at you know 40 retention at one
minute you're probably doing one or
multiple of these and it's not helping
your videos grow
okay so we just finished uh
a breakdown of 990 of our videos this
just happened on Tuesday so what day is
today Thursday so two days ago I haven't
even gone through all the data myself
yet but uh I had one of my guy my I have
a full-time data analyst on my team and
that's what he does is goes and looks
store data and gives us suggestions on
what's working what's not working and
you compiled this giant spreadsheet of
of which videos are popping hard you
know we're at 78 retention at one minute
in which ones are underperforming and so
I'm going to share with you some of the
insights that we found today which I'm
excited because I didn't even know some
of these things until Tuesday
um having a full-time data analyst
really really helps
uh so I'm excited let's dive in and look
at some of the some of the data Okay so
that first minute again our goal is to
capture attention so
multiple camera angles we found really
really has been helping and this is some
of the stuff that I used to do that I
haven't done as much it's it's shocking
when you look at your data you might
find oh something I was doing back in
2019 is actually outperforming what I'm
doing right now
and all of these numbers are for the
past 90 days on my channel so it's not
lifetime of video this worked I've been
around for 12 years or something so it's
not like this worked back in 2014 and it
doesn't work anymore all the stats is
basically the last 90 days so multiple
camera angles we did four transitions in
the first 15 seconds and that helped
lead to 78 at one minute
okay getting outside
switching up the background having some
color
again this one four transitions in 18
seconds 70 at one minute
so I'm seriously looking at okay what
what can we do besides just using I love
my studio but besides just using the
studio what else could we use where else
could we go now some of this requires
more editing this one is pretty simple
this one even if you're doing it
yourself you could just do different
camera angles
for the intro this is only for the first
minute don't worry about making it
highly produced
um I
value editing but I think ultimately
it's going to be your capabilities to
pull out great information it's going to
carry the day but in that first minute
especially the editing can can make a
difference to hook somebody's attention
so you could do this even if you're
filming on your own but if you have
somebody as a camera operator helping
you you can move the side move around
just have different angles and again
just getting outside if you can if it's
warm we got summer you know right here
so can you do anything outside uh to
just shake up the background just to
make it a little more interesting a
little more appealing
um one hack that Billy Jean loves doing
for his ads if you don't know Billie
Jean he's one of the the experts on on
advertisements so YouTube ads Facebook
ads Etc is go look up in your city what
are the top places that people like to
go to
and then try to film there
so it takes more time uh it takes more
budget it takes it takes a team to maybe
help you but if there's an interesting
background so I'm in Toronto there's you
know the CN tower there's Niagara Falls
there's you know different places but if
you look at the top places people like
to visit and then that happens to be in
your background that could help just get
people interested at the beginning
Fast Cuts so
here's an example where we did 10
transitions in 21 seconds
where we're doing a preview of things to
come and this is something that after
looking at the data on this we're going
to be playing with it instead of longer
clips
doing coming up leading with shorter
Clips but more of them as opposed to
longer more in-depth Clips really that
first minute is people are justifying
their time with you
I don't know who you are I like the
topic do I want to watch this video you
know it's like people will skim an
article before they read it that's
what's happening right now so if you can
give them a chance to skim the video
before they watch it you can hook them
in so this is something when we plan a
lot more with uh we're after seeing this
I just instructed my team hey I want our
next two weeks of videos on the top 10
Channel I want to be doing 10 cuts for
each one and let's see if we can play
this out so think about your own videos
think about your own content uh you
don't have to have 10 rules
but how can you take some of the
Highlight moments and instead of just
one or two highlight moments go for five
six seven eight highlight moments that
are in more in Rapid succession to say
okay there's a lot there's a lot of meat
coming up in this video
I want to watch it
so this this was really mind-blowing for
me this was some experiment we did I
don't know back in 2016 just as a as a
one-off and never went back to it for
whatever reason
it's like wait a minute that actually
worked let's go back and look at it and
you know when you have 10 000 videos
like I do on my channel uh there's a lot
of data to report to to get some
interesting information so super fast
Cuts I would definitely play with some
of these for your videos
so the topic today how do you reach out
to other YouTubers or people in your
field to collaborate with and I'm just
going to shorten this down to
collaboration so judging the value
okay this is a little bit controversial
uh the value of collaborations because
when I was first getting started
everybody said collab collab collab
collab you got to do a lot of collabs
you got to do a lot of collabs collabs
are the secret answer right it was it
was the buzzword I guess at the time and
I set out to try to do a lot of
collaborations the biggest one that I
did
earlier on in my in my channel growth
was was this one here with Charisma
command this is the biggest one that
I've done the channel that was that was
much bigger than mine right so now he's
got four and a half million subscribers
almost and he made this video on me
talking about
uh how to be a networker and I never
considered myself to be much of a
networker
but he called it the introvert's guide
to networking he called me a master
networker based off this event that um
we're both at for YouTubers and I
basically introduced a lot of people to
him uh my strategy for networking was
really just listen to what people need
and then try to introduce them to
somebody who can help them with that
much more than me going up to people and
say hey I'm Evan how are you
um I'm I I suck at that stuff but just
basically listen to what people need and
then help them and so with Charlie this
is Charlie who runs Charisma on command
that's what I did I just helped him at
the event say hey well what are you
trying to find then he he told me
um and I introduced him to a couple
people who I knew uh and then all of a
sudden I'm a master networker and he's
making a video I mean so this video
worked out pretty well it was super
um
humbling uh very complimentary and at
the end he even linked up my channel so
I I took a screenshot of this end card
because that's if you click on this you
go right to my channel and that's ideal
in a collaboration is that it's not just
a link in the description but that
they're actually linking you up on the
end card for them to go right to check
out your channel okay so I thought oh my
God my channel is going to blow up this
is amazing this giant YouTuber is
featuring me this is fantastic come on
let's go and then I looked at the data
like when is this video coming up he
told me he was making it it launches
let's go come on my channel is about to
explode
and then here were the numbers
so this is the day that the video came
out
so these are my Subs these are my Subs
gains so
I was gaining for this month right from
the from the first to the 17th I was
gaining 1088 Subs a day
then when that video came out I got two
thousand twenty one hundred the next day
was 1200 and then the next day was back
basically back to my average
so over the course of you know that
video coming up those two days that it
came up and popped I I got I gained an
extra 1200 Subs over my average right an
extra 12 12 over my average and that's
that was pretty good I mean it's decent
it didn't blow up like I thought it
would blow up uh it's kind of the you
know the Heartbreak every now and then
when you think something's gonna do
super well and then it just doesn't get
you the results it really made me start
the question is this even
worth it is it even worth spending all
this time doing this collaboration
versus just making another video I'm
already getting a thousand you know 88
Subs a day should I just prioritize
making videos instead of trying to set
up collaborations and and after this is
what I ended up really focusing is my
strategy to grow my channel I doubled
down on content creation not
collaborations
I was a big shift I love collaborations
I still do a whole ton of them but I
think for the the ability to grow your
channel the consistent content is going
to be your number one place to actually
get the results so
uh I've done a ton of collaborations I'm
doing a lot more today this Thursday is
my public facing day uh so the thing to
think about time travel coordination
expenses is it worth the extra effort
does it does it help sure but is it
worth all of that extra effort to try to
go off and do the collaboration now the
one with Charlie that I did on Christmas
command I was already in the the event
with him we were already there we're in
Palm Springs we're doing this this
YouTube event so I didn't have to do any
real extra work I was just trying to
help them out and a lot of
collaborations have happened at those
events now we don't obviously have those
events happening right now but at events
there's a lot of collaborations
happening at conferences where they pull
you aside to say hey can I do an
interview with you hey can we make this
happen
um and so those are always fun to do and
and can help your channel but if you're
gonna set up a separate thing just to do
it it may not be worth it uh is it is it
worth you to
on the back and forth on the
coordination on the travel and the
expenses all of that
if you're only looking at Subs game
there's other reasons to do it but if
you're only looking at Subs gained it
may not be worth it um again versus just
making videos my typical advice is just
go back to default making videos because
every video you make is another shot for
people to find you and it's usually
better for the long term results of your
channel I would say if they're 10 times
bigger than you those are the
collaborations that go after if it's
somebody who's just your size or smaller
if all you care about is channel growth
if there's no other value you love them
it's fine it's Biz Dev there's another
strategic reason if all you care about
is channel growth I would be looking at
only doing collaborations with people
who are 10 times bigger than you a lot
of times the value just isn't there to
do most collaborations and this is so
against typical advice that people give
but uh this has been my experience in
doing tons and tons of tons of
collaborations
um that unless they're much bigger than
you it's not going to drive a ton of
traffic
okay so then why do it why why do
collaborations why if we don't care
about if it's if it's not going to help
us with Channel growth as much as just
making content why do it well the first
is networking right yesterday we're
talking to pre-show too Pablo was
talking about my my one-on-one with
Jamie Kern Lima you know she just
created her book believe it we did an IG
live together we're both we both have
our eyes closed here because uh we're
doing a prayer I asked her to do a
Prayer live for us and she had never
done a Prayer live on Instagram so we
did one together
um and we're going to turn this into a
YouTube video so you know Jamie I've
known for a year we met I met her at
Brendan's uh house in in Puerto Rico and
she's part of our beach gang and it's
just good it's good karma it's good
networking to support the people in your
community who are doing things she went
from being a waitress and having a
thousand dollars in a bank account to
selling her business for 1.2 billion
cash so even if it doesn't blow up
channel it's still good for my business
it's still good for my relationship and
it's still just good karma to do and
it's fun I like doing it right much more
than this video is going to help blow up
my channel
okay brand building
I mean when I do an interview with Tony
Robbins uh that that could help the
channel obviously uh but it's a it's a
lot of work it's a lot of work lining up
big people it's a lot of work it's a lot
of work reaching out it's a lot of work
maintaining the relationship it's a lot
of work figuring out the times figuring
the technology it's a lot of work to
make this 21 minute interview happen but
it's great for the brand so there might
be people who you bring on who could
really help you with your your brand
that get you're connected to them even
if it doesn't help your channel grow
that much it just puts you into a
different world
um so we had Matthew McConaughey on the
channel recently we're working on Deepak
Chopra coming up uh you know a bunch of
other people that will help the channel
grow but probably not as much as if I
just spent time making videos but having
them on the channel elevates the brand
of the business that much more
so brand building Biz Dev
uh this was a client of mine Stephen
Kelly he used to run Sage Sage is an
accounting software company uh one of
the the footsie top 100 companies by
market cap in in the UK and he was the
CEO multi-billion dollar company and we
would do a bi-monthly so every every two
weeks is that bi-monthly or is that
anyway every two weeks we did a show
together on YouTube where we would
answer questions from the audience we'd
have a topic and they would answer
questions from the audience so that
series didn't help my channel grow but
but it was a business opportunity
right I mean if you look at the views on
those videos they probably did worse
than a typical video but it was a
business opportunity and and I grew to
really love Stephen and his View and his
perspective so it was super fun to do
but again the value isn't just in the
growing the channel the value is in the
business relationship
um and then it's fun
I mean I I think people discount just
having fun is a good thing I'm gonna do
a whole bunch of interviews today and
most of them will be on smaller channels
you know like this one I don't I don't
remember who this guy was
um or what his channel is but it's fun
like I just like I like being the first
person on people's channels a lot of
times I'm the first person ever
interviewed and then they use that
interview to go get other people to say
hey we had Evan on the channel do you
want to join as well
um so I just found it super fun to do
even if there's no immediate Roi
um one example there's a guy named Nick
who I was one of the first guys to reach
out to him he started an Instagram
account
called book thinkers
four years ago when I launched my book
year one word I said Nick love the work
you're doing love to send you a copy of
my my book it was a tiny Instagram
account at the time and
he later said I was the first guy first
author to reach out to him I was the
first author to say to recognize him and
say good work and can I send you a a
signed book
fast forward to now you know three four
years later I launched build the serve
and all of a sudden Nick has the largest
network of Instagram accounts for uh
non-fiction
authors right so he's he's profiling
non-fiction book non-fiction book
reviews and he's got the largest network
of Instagram accounts for it and when I
said hey I got Bill to serve do you want
to review it and now I haven't really
been in touch with Nick for the past
three years in between that
but when I sent it to him I said yeah
I'm down thank you so much you helped
you helped kick-start my Instagram
career you were the first author to
support me and he he's been a massive
help in getting the word out for a bill
to serve
um I helped him watch a podcast I was
the first guest on his podcast and then
he had all these other people Grant
Cardone and Jim quick and all those guys
on as well now I didn't know that Nick
was going to be this guy and most people
flame out most people if you're their
first guest on their show most people
don't take it seriously and and stop and
quit and they only they only go five
episodes deep or some people never even
release the episode
but just sit on it it's like whatever
happened to that interview that we did
together like oh I don't know I gave up
uh but every now and then you get
somebody who pops and I think it's just
it's just fun if you I see it as fun I
see it as community service I see it as
giving back to you know entrepreneurs
and YouTubers because when I was getting
started I really struggled uh and so
I don't care if it generates traffic or
interest for the channel or not it's not
a strategy it's more just it fills the
soul so probably half the interviews I'm
going to do today after this are not
strategic just somebody I like or
somebody's story who I like and I want
to I want to help them
um and eventually a lot of those come
back to pay off if you stick in the game
long enough a lot of those do come back
to help
I want to talk about end mid and
pre-roll placements or advertisements to
help spread more awareness for what
you're doing
so ending CTA this is something that I'm
experimenting with Brendan burchard
so Brendan and I partnered up on his uh
a bunch of things that one of them is
his growth day YouTube channel and the
goal is strictly get people to sign up
for growth day what is growth day growth
day is his new personal development
program app it's designed to every
ideally every day have somebody going
live people who you know like respect
training on personal development could
be branding could be Mel Robbins could
be David Bach Dave Hollis all these
people to have them train and then you
pay one monthly fee and then you sign up
what we're doing is doing clips of his
videos and this this is part of his
Morning Show but this is going to expand
having Clips as his videos
and then on the end card is Brendan
saying hey if you want to like today's
the day you want to learn you want to
grow you want to set for growth day go
click the link on this page
and this is blank right now because we
just started the channel I have to get
the 4 000 hours of watch time
to be able to qualify so we've got the
Thousand subscribers now we just need
the 4 000 hours watch time
um but this is going to be a link that
people can then click to go off and sign
up for growth day
it's less of a let's build the channel
up that's more of a long-term play let's
build the channel up let's get tons of
subscribers to learn about Grote and
more immediate at the end of every video
Let's promote growth day and get them to
click on the link right
we have found tremendous success I don't
know if I've talked about the side
inside of brainlytics yet but we found
tremendous success with on the end card
just having one big call to action
instead of having multiple so typically
if you go back on my channel you'll see
that we had four things on the end card
there was the a video that you pick
another video or playlist that you pick
a subscribe button and a link to my
website
and we found that as an experiment we
just tried one
and on most of my videos if you go and
look at my my content now you'll see
there's one big call to action which is
to watch another video
so if you want more from XYZ go click
the video right there I'll see you there
you're gonna love it and then looking
and pointing to to go there the clicks
on that one video
are getting more clicks than the other
four elements combined
so now if you look at any of the
channels you'll see like these arrows
flying in and people that were doing
work you know Consulting helping with
recommending the same thing
um different styles of arrows but
basically all these arrows looking
pointing like go click on this thing
so it's worth a test I haven't done
enough and I don't know enough people
who are doing the ending ctas like this
to drive to an offer instead of another
video
but it's worth an experiment
to see hey this is an option for me
because in my end card in your end cards
you can link to another video provided
you're in the partnership program and if
you're not it's at least something you
know about that you can build towards
but it could make a big difference for
getting people to click over to your
site it says new big passion project
um turning it into an app or I think the
app is actually already out or it's
about to be out
um but yeah it's awesome to see so much
change in addition to the personal
development field so this is something
to play with I don't do it on my main
Channel but we're doing it for Brendan
on this growth day because the number
one goal is get people into growth day
um
Ashley this could be an experiment for
one of your videos right hey this is
from our tapping app you want to sign up
for it it's right there go click it
check it out and measure to see how many
clicks you're getting from it
so that's the ending CTA
what I usually do is the mid Shadow and
this is much easier to uh
Implement as well as not impact where
people go next because if you're doing
this one we're having a heavy focus on
getting people to go to somewhere else
besides YouTube where if your goal is to
grow the channel and make it as big as
possible you want to increase watch time
and so you want to have a video at the
end that you're guiding people towards
and it's always much better to have you
picking the most relevant video and you
calling out that specific video to go
check out than just having best reviewer
or or most recent okay
I do this one a lot myself personally so
somewhere in the middle of every video
we have some kind of call to action so
this is one that I did uh for the book
so one of the advice that Brendan gave
me for the book is have different people
read the book he said one of his biggest
strategies to help him launch his book
was he had people like Larry King and
all these other people uh read a section
from the book and he turned that into
video content to help promote the book
so my first question was okay would you
be my first Brendan do you want to read
the book and he said yes and my heart
was beaten to asking for that and then I
used that and got other people so a lot
of my videos probably half of the videos
on my main channel will have a mid shout
out here of somebody reading the book so
this is example of Jay Shetty but you
know we've got
uh Grant Cardone and and Kevin O'Leary
and Ed my Ladd and lots of people in in
personal development that you probably
know and recognize and then it's check
the link in the description to get your
copy
so we're interrupting our video in the
middle this one is at this is a 30
something minute video and this happens
at the 10 56 mark
so somewhere in the middle of the video
if you do this kind of shout out at the
beginning of the video you're going to
lose people because they don't know who
you are they're not ready for an offer
your retention is gonna gonna drop
if you do it at the end like this one
you're also going to lose a lot of
attention because they just feel that
it's a pitch
um what's the advantage is you can
actually have them click right here
instead of having to click in the
description
when you do it in the middle
there's usually very little retention
drop
because you've gotten them to watch in
this case you know 11 minutes of a video
so they're they're interested they're
engaged
and they know that there's still another
you know 20 minutes left
so they want to stick around for what's
coming next
uh so Tom bilyu has changed his strategy
and does a good job of this now where
he'll have a super quick mention at the
beginning but he'll interrupt his own
interviews
at an appropriate point to talk about
whoever the sponsor is of the video
so somewhere in the middle of the video
in the most appropriate Place possible
normally for something like this you
know if we're doing 10 hard choices you
need to make in life we've probably
included a Jay Shetty compilation of
video somewhere here and then right
after you watch the J Shetty clip
there's Jay Shetty reading the book
right after you're watching Grant
Cardone interview like there's Grant
Cardone and I talking about the book
so this is to get people to
click the link it's in the description
we can't have it you know clickable here
as a big button like we can with other
ones
but we can have them to go click on the
link down below
uh Drew says is that mid shout out baked
into the video or you buy the ad slot
this is baked into the video this is
organic baked into the video you could
buy ad spots as well and we'll talk
about that the pre-roll is usually
better than the mid
um because we time it specifically
around something that I'm talking about
so Jay Shetty shows up after J Shetty
clip Grant Cardone shows up after Grant
Cardone clip the even the topic so Jay
Shetty would read this section he read
was about relationships
uh talking to Grant Cardone or somebody
else is going to be a slightly different
topic there's different parts in the
book The Brandon Richard one talked
about purpose the clip that he read from
my book so also trying to match it with
the theme of the video
so if you're thinking about you're
making a video you're gonna have a call
to action somewhere in the middle
while you're talking about your content
if you're going to make a 20 minute
video or 10 minute video
at what point somewhere in the middle
you know like in the one third the
two-thirds Mark does it make the most
relevant sense to talk about whatever
offer you've got
so you can customize it when you're
buying a mid-roll ad spot that makes it
a lot you it's a lot more difficult you
could do it it's a lot more manual to
like put a manual ad spot right here and
then to target that with your own ad
um and this is organic and free
so it's a constant driver people keep
watching this video
this kind of thing is better for a
consistent ongoing offer so
I'm still going to care about build to
serve in five years it's not just my
2021 marketing strategy and then I'm
moving on to something else because I
don't care about the book anymore like
it's it's a part of me I care about it
it's deeply important to me so I'm okay
with this living inside my video for the
next five years this is not good for I'm
launching this thing next week
go sign up
right because most of the views will not
happen inside the next week
today's topic was my process to review
Channel analytics so frequency is the
easiest one to understand
I would say for for you guys once a week
is the minimum
once a week is is table Stakes once a
week is just just getting into the game
and however you can make that as easy as
possible I'm going to share some some
calendar ideas for you some types of
content that you can make that might
make it easier for you to produce you
have expertise your thought leaders you
are genius at something to to lower the
burden of the production costs because
you're not in the production business if
you were uh if you were a camera
operator if you were an editor your
stuff better look good my editor's real
better look fire because they're an
editor don't let that be the barrier so
once a week
is the bare minimum
three times a week I'd say is the goal
and that that
becomes scary for people so again
looking at batching the content and
looking at content types that you can
produce really quickly
uh and seven times a week would be
ambitious like ultimately if you can get
to seven times a week after seven times
a week
I'd recommend a different Channel like
if you're going hardcore you want to
have you want to go twice a day
put it on a different Channel I used to
be at three times a day on my main
Channel
and YouTube used to be that when you had
uh
when I went once a day I saw a huge
boost when I went from Once to twice a
day I saw another huge boost went from
twice a day to three times a day I saw a
little boost it was diminishing returns
but YouTube's changed
um they're not really rewarding channels
for going multiple times per day so I'd
say once a day at the max maybe nobody's
there in this group yet or thinking
about it might be like you're crazy I've
been thinking about one time a day but
it's it's doable to create you know when
on my Tuesdays I make 60 videos
so it's doable to create now they
couldn't all be hour and a half sessions
but throughout the day even even as I go
through today
uh later today I'm doing an interview
with Tony Robbins for my channel I'm
going to be doing a bunch of different
podcasts and and Skype calls with people
for their Channel that I can cut and use
on my channel I'm I'm doing it we have
this live I'm doing a live inside my
readers group
um so you can plan your days to have one
big day either per week or per month to
create the content so that you have an
effect an effective schedule to go off
and actually create consistent content
if you just kind of hope and and wait
for you to have free time to do it
you're probably never going to have free
time to do it so you gotta put it in
your calendar to actually make sure that
it happens Laura Cobb has a question
says what if I'm comfortable being on
camera
yet I'm not sure how to set it up if
it's just a how the how to's are
everywhere on YouTube like how to set up
my camera and you'll find lots of videos
on how to do it I am not super worried
about the gear like I'm not the gear guy
I don't know what microphone this is I
don't know what camera I'm using you
know we're doing zoom and PowerPoint
like I I really don't care too much
about the gear
um I'm still making videos from from my
iPhone
you know there'll still be videos on my
channel that go live from me holding the
iPhone and walking so the how is always
pretty easy to figure out getting
comfortable on camera is the hard part
so if you're comfortable on camera press
record start making videos and get
better people get too locked up in the
gear and how to do it the gear really
doesn't matter too much as long as we
can hear you uh Nico is asking is it
better to post seven times a week a
short video four to six or three to four
times a week 10 minute minimum I go
longer I look at 10 minutes as as the as
the barrier like try to get to 10
minutes every time eight at a minimum
minimum minimum but try to get to 10
minutes as you're going through it
um it's really hard to get a four minute
font leadership video to rank
so I'd much rather you be at four times
a week ten minutes plus just think about
how you can go deeper tell me another
story give me another example uh take me
deeper into the advice that you're going
to give instead of giving me one one bit
of advice give me three if you follow
the if you're making thought leadership
videos and you follow the template and
build the serve that gives you like go
to the end right how to turn your your
your passion into profit uh that thought
leadership template
by the time you go through it you have a
powerful statement you have a context
sentence you raise the stakes you tell
me a story you address the Hedge and
then you give me your three bits of
advice on what I need to do that's easy
a 10 minute video
so I'll be looking at 10 minutes still
as a minimum anyway so that's that's the
calendar that I would look at once a
week minimum three times a week is the
goal and seven times a week would be
ambitious so how do we do it right how
do we do it like you look at that you
say oh my God that's crazy number one
has to be batching content batch batch
batch batch batch of content set aside a
day or half a day to make content
if you set aside half a day
per month
you could make four videos in that time
and have a video a week if we're talking
about just bare minimum to get started
for people who are are starting and
stopping starting and stopping right
because the time by the time you just
get set up and put the cameras on and
and just get into the vibe and the zone
of being ready to make a video and get
the the nerves out and everything else
you could make more videos in that time
the time it takes you to make your first
video and the setup you could make three
four more videos in that same amount of
time so you so batching content and
creating a day so this is when I used to
film in my studio this picture my that
was at my dance studio people ask me if
that was a green screen behind me like
why did you put a shopping mall as a
green screen it's like because it's not
a green screen
I'm in the mall This is my dance studio
um so I would have my camera guy set up
and we would film
a whole bunch of videos all day long
right and I'd have one giant session per
month where it'd be you know 8 A.M to 6
p.m almost straight and just taking a
break whenever I needed to go to the
bathroom or eat something and then just
keep go go go go go go go go
um and I would make crazy number of
videos and then mini videos during the
week so thinking about your own calendar
what is a a feasible execution for you
where you can say I'm going to set aside
half a day a month or half a day a week
to make content because once you're on
YouTube you can be everywhere
right once you're on YouTube and you're
making long videos you can cut those up
and be on every platform
so YouTube is our long-form home it's
our base and then we're splitting up the
content to be everywhere
does that make sense so there's the
thought leadership content which the the
best template is in build to serve at
the end uh coaching
which is you basically just showing up
mentoring is when you're taking the same
person and and going back for round two
and round three or round four around
five so think about some of the people
that you have helped who you just have a
great Vibe with who you love being with
who they take your advice and they do
something with it
and then having a series with them to
say hey do you want to turn this into a
monthly Series so we can then check in
with them and see how they're doing and
hopefully they're taking the advice and
they're growing and they're learning and
they're improving
uh so that's mentoring interviews you
could be interviewing other people for
your Channel
so
uh you know I I don't like an interview
only Channel because I want you to be
the thought leader and the expert but as
part of a Content mix that could be
great
and then the last content type is Q A
and Q a is where you're basically just
taking questions from your audience so
you can look at your comments you can
look at your
um your YouTube comments your Instagram
comments any other social network or
people are asking you questions if you
have no questions coming in yet then you
can look at other people's comments
because chances are that guy is not
answering his comments
and so Ryan can say hey I saw this come
you don't have to say this comment was
on my channel right we're not lying here
because I saw this comment that said
this and here's how I would answer it
whatever the comments are on your own
channels first but if nothing then go to
other people's comments go to my
comments I mean we're responding to all
the comments but it's not me doing
everything go to garyvee or Grant
Cardone or anybody who's in your
industry I'm thinking of the people in
my in my field but in your industry look
at their comments take five to ten
questions and turn it into a video
if you want to see this full video as
well as trained live with me twice a
month to blow up your brand join the
brand Linux training program there's a
link to join right there next to me and
to believe